so now there are calls to boycott Disney
the mainstream media is picking it up
and there are a bunch of photos popping
up all over X of people showing they've
cancelled their subscriptions to all of
these companies that announced
Advertiser boycotts on X after Elon Musk
said go f yourself you will not
blackmail me essentially many people
joined in and now there's big pushes for
people to sign up for X premium and to
cancel their subscription to any one of
these companies stop servicing these
companies to boycott any company that
played politics
to put it simply this is not just a
company being like well we don't want to
run ads on X anymore it's all of these
companies at the same time teaming up
with political activists to negatively
impact a business that isn't taking the
political stance they want this should
get very very interesting so we'll talk
about that we've got the CEO of X
doubling down and telling all of the
staff we believe in free speech and we
won't back down from this from from
their position awesome